on behalf of Columbia University's world
leaders forum and the School of
International and public affairs Gabriel
silver memorial endowed lecture series
I'd like to thank all of you for joining
us tonight as we welcome mr. yukiya
amano to speak with us today mr. Amato
is director-general of the international
atomic energy agency the agency and
intergovernmental organization is the
global center for cooperation and
nuclear applications energy science and
technology established in 1957 the
agency works with member states and
partners to promote safe secure and
peaceful nuclear technologies and
prevent the proliferation of nuclear
weapons prior to his current position
mr. Romano's served as chair of the
agency's board of governors from
September of 2005 to September of 2006
he was Japan's Resident Representative
to the agency from 2005 until his
election as director-general in 2009 mr.
Romano has extensive experience in
disarmament and non-proliferation
diplomacy as well as nuclear energy
issues and has been involved in
negotiation of major international
instruments he held increasingly senior
positions in the Japanese Foreign
Ministry which he joined in 1972 notably
is director of the science division
director of the nuclear energy division
director of general for arms control and
scientific affairs and most recently
director-general for the disarmament
non-proliferation science department
which he held from 2002 to 2005 he also
served as a government expert on the UN
panel on missiles and on the UN expert
group on Disarmament and
non-proliferation education mr. Amano
contributed to the 1995 two thousand and
two thousand and five nuclear
non-proliferation treaty review
conferences and chaired the 2007
preparatory committee for the 2010
non-proliferation treaty
view conference as a graduate of the
Tokyo University Faculty of Law mr.
Romano is served with the Embassy of
Japan in Belgium France Laos Switzerland
and the United States the International
Atomic Energy Agency serves as a global
forum for scientific and technical
cooperation in the peaceful uses of
nuclear power it provides international
safeguards against the misuse of nuclear
technology and nuclear materials and
promotes nuclear safety including
radiation protection and nuclear
security standards and their
implementation in the light of this
year's events at the Fukushima nuclear
plant the importance of this work cannot
be overstated we need large scale safe
non-fossil fuel based energy to meet the
expanding energy energy needs of a
population which just yesterday reached
7 billion and is still growing but we
cannot move full speed ahead with
nuclear or any energy solution for that
matter without the necessary protections
and safeguards and that is where the
agency's key role as a leader in this
field and technical advisor become so
critical and so I'd like to welcome mr.
Amano to talk about this important work
there'll be time for questions following
his remarks so please hold all questions
until that point I'll come up and start
the question-and-answer session and I
should mention that when we get to the
question and answer session since we'd
like to hear our guests answers I'd like
you to ask questions instead of
commenting on whatever whatever it is
you'd like to say so with that mr. Manto
please join us
good evening ladies and gentlemen jack
colleagues it was some several months
ago that i received an invitation from
the International and public school for
of International and public affairs at
Columbia University usually I cannot
make decision immediately I hesitate but
this time I decided right away to accept
this invitation because I have a reason
it was some 40 years ago that i came to
new york in the framework of other
program called asian student leader
program i was not the leader of japanese
or student movement but perhaps the
American Embassy in Washington either in
New York in Tokyo made a mistake and I
was picked up as a student leader it was
lucky I went to Hawaii I visited 13
states on the east coast and i came to
new york i was discussing with a
professor that 40 years ago New York was
a different place it was quite dangerous
but during the daytime my escort took us
to the United Nations we visited them
conference room of the General Assembly
with a podium I met with the ambassadors
for the first time in my life and I
thought perhaps one day I come to New
York again and make a speech from the
podium of the General Assembly and can't
believe me I made it today I spoke I
spoke from the podium and I explained
about the activities of whom are the
IAEA so I'm today
rehearsed so let me start by talking
about the FEMA daijah accident since
March this year I had to use lots of
time and energy to deal with undef
kashima Daiichi accident in Japan when I
became the director general I thought I
do not want another accident will happen
and especially not in Japan but despite
my expectation accident happened and it
was in Japan on them 11 submerge it was
just after the Board of Governors Board
of Governors starting on the 7th of bars
and 43 everything went well and we
finished on Thursday tenth of March and
then I was relaxed in the morning I woke
up and so are the CNN and I learned that
an earthquake of vista 7 occurred of the
coast of japan as i was working in the
in this field i immediately thought this
is quite serious but reached a 7 is not
extremely serious try to contact with
from my special assistant and ensured
that the incident an emergency center of
the IAEA is activated it was the case
then I started to take breakfast and
later I learned it was a mistake it was
not reached out seven but reached and
nine and then came the huge tsunami that
time I understood clearly this is a this
there will be a huge accident during the
weekend iraq i recorded video tape and
starting from monday i briefed the
member states and media on on the
accident
but information was quite limited I
didn't have enough information coming
from Japan I had to establish a good
team in Vienna and someone suggested me
and to go to Japan and I wonder how I
better to go to Japan or hara better to
stay in Vienna I was like Hamlet but I
decided to go to go to Japan one of the
reasons and that I had a date for that
there was no appointment when I took the
flight I wanted to see on the prime
minister but there was no appointment
but I took the risk and when I landed I
learned that meeting with the Prime
Minister was some concept from the
airport of Narita i went to the prime
minister's office directory and when I
met him I told him everyone is worrying
about Japan Japan is not alone but
everyone is is some everyone supporting
Japan but everyone is wearing about
Japan so the most important thing for
Japan is to tell everything to ensure
the highest level of transparency the
Prime Minister nodded and instructed his
stuff to provide the information to the
IAEA as a matter of priority later the
flow of information improved a lot to
make the long story short i convened a
ministerial meeting in June which
adopted the ministerial declaration in
September the general conference of the
IAEA adopted an action plan that
consists of 12 points the situation in
Mishima daiji is that the assessment of
the IAEA
is that them reactors that were crippled
are generally stable and the Japanese
government and under the operator are
very confident that they can bring the
reactors are to our stable situation
which is called code shut down so we are
moving from the accident hand-wringing
phase to the post accident phase what do
we have to do first the Japanese
government needs to decontaminate the
off site where people are forced to
evacuate as long as people are evacuated
from 20 kilometer 30-kilometer radius we
can never say that the accident is over
well confidence in nuclear power is
restored on the international arena
implementation of the action plan is the
first priority I do not go into details
that the 12-point covers like reviewing
and strengthening the safety standard or
all the countries that have nuclear
power plants have to conduct so-called
stress tests IAEA will strengthen its
function to send international expert
review missions international response
and preparedness will be strengthened
these are some of the main thrust of the
action plan and in my view if the
secretariat countries member states
operators and others I mean all the
stakeholders if all the stakeholders
implement this action plan nuclear power
will be much safer in the near future
I would like to achieve concrete results
in the coming 12 months accident
recovering from Kassadin takes time in
case of from three miles accident it
took years to clearly understand what
happened in the core in case of general
we don't know exactly what are the
conceptual consequences what are the
real reason still the word is becoming
very impatient the pace of life is fast
and some we cannot say please wait five
years one year two years are the maximum
of patience of the people and if we do
our best we can do lots of things in one
year or two years what is most damaged
by this accident is the confidence so we
need tangible results to restore the
confidence next issue is what will be
the future of the nuclear power just
after the accident Germany decided to
phase out from the nuclear Switzerland
decided not to construct new new nuclear
power plants after the lifetime of the
existing nuclear power plant expired
that will be 2034 and in japan too we
had a lot of things that future is very
unstable IAEA is some making projections
every young and in light of our latest
projection I am very confident that this
is not the end of nuclear power now we
have 432 reactors in the world in
operation 432 according to our
projection by 2030 at least there will
be nine
more reactors or 350 more reactors now
we have 432 and they will be increased
by 90 or 350 this is by no means the end
of the nuclear why this home in my view
the fundamental conditions surrounding
nuclear power have not changed before
and after kashima let's take up the
climate change until quite recently all
the leaders in the world said climate
change is the number one problem in the
world and nuclear nuclear problems do
not emit co2 fossil fuel is a very
expensive resource and the price is
going up and up and it has limited in
its some stock everyone every country
would like to ensure energy security
these conditions have not changed so it
is quite understandable that many
countries continue to maintain nuclear
power as an option in order to avoid
misunderstanding I have to add that we
are not recommending nuclear power we
are not intervening in the decision of
countries it is up to each country to
decide whether or not to use nuclear
power we do not intervene but even
countries decide to use nuclear power we
the IAEA is prepared to help them in
order to let them use safely securely
sustainably and without increasing the
risk of proliferation
next issue that I would like to take up
is done nuclear security you may be
familiar of with the nuclear safe
security but to be sure I would like to
explain what I mean by nuclear security
nuclear security means the F also
measures to prevent nuclear material or
radioactive material falling into the
hands of terrorists some of you may
argue that can happen it really the case
the IAEA has a database and this
database is called illicit trafficking
database and every year on average we
receive 180 report on the illicit
trafficking of nuclear material of all
radioactive materials this year from
january to july we have received 172
reports and we are not sure whether we
know everything this may be only the tip
of iceberg if this is the case this is a
real threat quite often people ask me
which is the most dangerous country I
cannot expect that they are expecting me
to say some name some country I don't do
that but I say the country or the
individual who do not recognize this
risk is the most dangerous country and
the most dangerous person the reason is
that carries always exploit the weakest
think I have this experience in my
previous capacity I was dealing with a
nuclear security and when a country
country trying to procure certain
material from
I'm not nuclear material they move they
target from one port to another when
under control of one port is tightened
they shift to another port so they
always terrorists always target for the
weakest link so we need to get prepared
how can we get prepared one way is to
collect information as we are doing if
you know if you have the information you
can analyze the trend and based on this
data you can establish the response this
is the basis and when you understand
that trend next thing is to train people
the iaea have trained since 2002 over
10,000 people IAEA is not a huge
developing development organization but
from time to time we provide equipment
you have known you may not have seen the
nuclear detectors I didn't bring it
today but some it is some like this a
little bit bigger than this it costs
about 1000 euro and it is very effective
if you have some someone has nuclear
material I can I can detect it with this
equipment more sophisticated equipment
costs more but an equipment of the size
or from blackberry costing 1000 is
effective enough there are those up from
important events in the world in the
past beijing olympics or world football
game or next year we'll have london
olympics IAEA is training people and
providing equipment so that here
would not abuse are these events I'm
sure that you will see London Olympics
so when you see it please think of the
idea staff who are working behind the
monitor next I would like to talk about
non-proliferation which is one of the
core activities of the IAEA but before
that let me explain you some basic
things we have the non-proliferation
treaty and except for five countries
United States Russia France UK China all
the countries are committed not to have
nuclear weapons and those countries
which are called non-nuclear weapon
States under the NPT are obliged are to
conclude agreement with the IAEA which
is called comprehensive safeguard a
country that conclude comprehensive
safeguard need to declare all the
nuclear materials and activities to the
IAEA and when we receive such
declaration we send inspectors and check
if everything is correct we check the
inventory we listen are two on the
people and check everything is properly
recorded and then we install camera and
we stall sales for example and continue
to monitor that there will be no change
if countries declare their materials and
activities properly and if I inspect us
the proper job nuclear material and
activities will never be used for
purposes other than peaceful purposes
but unfortunately people sometimes
conceal concealer activities it happened
in Iraq we tried we trusted people but
our trust was betrayed Iraq concealed
activities to our inspectors and try to
develop nuclear weapons it was before
other than the first Iraq war the same
things happened in North Korea or Libya
after Iraq incident the IAEA developed
new scheme which is called Additional
Protocol Additional Protocol is a more
intrusive scheme it is complicated but
in essence says even though our country
conceals their activities the IAEA can
request that country to give us access
to locations people and information this
Additional Protocol is a very effective
tool for the IAEA to have confidence
that all the activities and material in
the country is only for peaceful purpose
now we have 112 countries that are that
have brought the Additional Protocol
into force let me explain about Iran
Iran is a special case special case
because although one is a non-nuclear
weapon stage and has concluded safeguard
agreement with IAEA it concealed
activities for a long time for some 20
years in 2003 it was found that Iran was
in violation
in failure of the their safeguard
obligations it was decided that Iran was
in non-compliance with the IAEA
safeguards agreement the board decided
it was in non-compliance and reported to
the Security Council and in response
Security Council adopted resolutions the
resolution contains there are several
reservations about the main first are
requesting Iran to cooperate free with
the IAEA to suspend the enrichment and
reprocessing related activities and
implement additional plan addition
protocols and this some this some
reservation was some subsequently
strengthened now economic sanctions or
restriction of the movement of people
are imposed as these regulations were
adopted under the chapter 7 of the
United Nations it is legally binding I
said Iran is a special case special case
because Iran has to implement
comprehensive safeguard and other
relevant obligations which include the
United Nations Security Council
resolutions but a factory that Iran is
not implementing United Nations Security
Council resolutions on top of that we
have the information that some of the
activities are not declared and some of
the activities may have military
implications under this condition i can
say that iranian nuclear material and
activities declared to the IAEA
stay in peaceful purposes but I cannot
give the inference that all the
materials in Iran are for peaceful
purposes that is why I am asking Iran to
implement all them safeguard obligations
and other relevant obligations since I
became the director general of the IAEA
I apply a very simple rule to all the
countries that is that all the countries
have to implement the comprehensive
safeguard and other relevant safeguard
obligations fully and this is a very
important standard it is not applied
only to Iran but it is applied to all
the countries Japan or Italy or whatever
country whether they are developed or
developing countries let me talk about d
BLK north korea in one sense situation
in North Korea is worse than in Iran
North Korea declared to have withdrawn
from the MGP expelled our inspectors and
since april two thousand nine we don't
have any inspectors in North Korea
recently there are reports that on the
construction of light water reactors and
enrichment facilities in North Korea
this is a very troubling situation
looking from Vienna Iranian nuclear
issues seems to be the most important as
I come from them different region of the
world I know that the new creation of
North Korea is very serious for the
security
of the region and Beyond on Syria in
2009 the facility in at the site called
daya assume this is an the name of the
location in the Syrian desert there was
an installation of our facility was the
facility was destroyed reportedly by
Israel this case was brought to the
attention of the IAEA in 2008 and the
IAEA sent inspectors but when we sent
inspectors the facility was already
destroyed cleared and but we could find
the particles nuclear particles I
succeeded this da cm in december two
thousand nine and I requested Syria to
accept our inspectors but Syria
continued to stonewalling I collected
information I collected satellite
imagery procurement information and some
by this spring I was able to draw a
conclusion there are two options to
continue to ask Syria to accept our
inspectors or to draw conclusion while i
am not one hundred percent sure while I
don't have the smoking gun and I decided
to draw a conclusion because the
function of the IAEA is to prevent the
proliferation if our mission is to
prevent the proliferation it is the
right thing for us or to draw a
conclusion when we have sufficient
information so i drew a conclusion that
it is very likely that they destroyed
facility
daya ozone was a reactor nuclear reactor
that should have been declared to the
IAEA the board of governors of the IAEA
decided that Syria was in non-compliance
with the IAEA safeguard and it was
reported to the United Nations Security
Council I have talked about Adam
proliferation nuclear accident but let
me speak talk about more positive
stories IAEA is known as a nuclear
watchdog but in reality we are involved
in many other areas let me give you one
example the IAEA has an expertise in
nuclear medicine and radio therapy
cancer was perceived as a disease by
disease of developed countries which is
some completely wrong it is true that
cancer is jason is a very serious
disease the death by cancer is more than
tuberculosis malaria HIV combined but
two-thirds of death by cancer occur in
developing countries not in developed
countries and two-thirds of cancer
patients come to clinic in developing
countries come too late so we cannot
give life-saving treatment after I
became the director general I went to
Nigeria as my first destination and i
visited the cancer hospital there I
heard that in the western part of Africa
women having breast cancer ashamed of
themselves
say farewell to the family leave the
home hide themselves and die without
being treated at all there's a social
stigma this is very humane this should
not continue so I decided that cancer
should be the highest priority issue in
the first year of my tenure and I have
the privilege of meeting with on the
world leaders so whenever I see them I
said we should establish the cancer
control in developing countries as a
global health agenda unfortunately we
have not come at that point but cancer
in developing countries is much much
better recognized in the world IAEA is
not an eight organization but we can
train people we can provide equipment to
some extent i was very pleased that when
I went to Albania I saw a cancer
equipment cobalt equipment donated by us
and in two three months they diagnosed
over 3,000 people that's a good record
but the other side of story is that if
that equipment is down no one can be
diagnosed why is needed and this
situation exists in many African
countries many African countries do not
have any equipment at all and to maybe
to your surprise some of the former
Eastern European countries are in very
bad shape in this field so we need to do
more other example of the peaceful use
of nuclear techniques is in water water
is a very scarce resource in the world
now
and over 1 billion people in the world
do not have proper access to water to
drinking water but nuclear technique is
very effective to detect and control
underground water and I I went to
Ecuador and I went to the countryside
and I've met with fishermen on the coast
they don't know nuclear text at all but
they benefit from the techniques it was
a bit is a very dry area but now they
have are they have from a drinking water
not only for themselves but they can
avoid to the tourists tourists that's a
very nice surfing area and I saw lots of
Americans coming to that area and Adam
local people are doing very good
business the climate change is one of
the greatest problem in the world ocean
and seas are the most precious
environment asset of the human beings
and we can better assess the condition
of oceans and seas by using isotopes we
have a laboratory in Monaco and that
laboratory is specialized in the
monitoring of oceans and seas conditions
nicoletta click play a very important
role in the monitoring another example
is the algal bloom because of the
climate change some arms develop very
easily and that is very poisonous if we
don't prevent then grow it will cause
lots of harm's including fatal harms of
other human beings nuclear tech needs
is very helpful or to detect analyze and
prevent such arms my last example is
some production of food I went to Peru
this summer and land that Highland over
unders are provide very rich source of
new species people there go high up in
the undertow collect new species and
develop new mutants which are more
resilient to diseases or give more
important yield this is very effective
to address them food crisis we have
learned that quite recently that global
population is getting over seven billion
and it is obvious that we don't have
enough food mutants developed by the use
of nuclear techniques will be one of the
solutions to address that situation
another example is the elimination of
animal diseases in September I attended
our ceremony to commemorate the
elimination of rinderpest in the past is
a disease that kill animals and it
causes damage of over 1 billion u.s.
dollars every year in Africa but by
using nuclear techniques we have
eradicated rinderpest in the history of
human beings we have eradicated two
diseases one in smallpox of our human
being another is win the best of all
animals and nuclear techniques was was
or essential
to this project of eradication of
rinderpest now perhaps it is time to
conclude but I would like to say that
IAEA was established in 1957 at that
time perhaps the countries that were
suspected of developing nuclear weapons
were not the countries like a BLK or it
will not Iran that have the
proliferation problems but now it is
these countries that have problems
nuclear terrorism was not an issue
perhaps 50 years ago but now it is top
of the security agenda food security
concern in developing countries water
shortage all of these are problems which
did not sow salient 50 years ago but
they are the most important issues in
the world today so as the director
general of the IAEA I would like to
address these issues both the prevention
of proliferation of nuclear weapons and
peaceful use of nuclear techniques in
the context of 21st century and I think
this is exactly the objective of the
IAEA atoms for peace thank you very much
mr. Romano has agreed to answer a few
questions so if you'd like to raise a
question please come to the microphone
and and ask again I ask four questions
not speeches is Mike right there I mr.
Romano you you talked about how you
could provide small devices possibly
handheld devices to detect threats of
terrorism at major events such as the
London Olympics and stuff what do you
think is the biggest threat to security
today is it small-scale terrorism at for
instance the London Olympics as a major
event or is it large-scale bomb building
by countries like Iran and North Korea
we have not detected large amount of
nuclear material but we have from
detected or we have on the report of
having detected or the highly enriched
uranium on some the highly enriched
uranium was very well packed so we
suspect that this is some a part of the
bigger amount we do not know how much
amount is circulating in the black
market how capable theorists are to
develop nuclear weapons but if they have
this such material fall into the hands
of our theories it is easy to make a
dirty bomb for example dirty bomb means
an a-bomb that do not explode by the
fusion or fission but by chemical
chemical function and some if dirty bomb
is used in cities like in New York that
will cause a huge panic and the effect
will be beyond imagination
and we cannot identify the size of bombs
but we can tell that terrorists can use
nuclear material and if they do the
consequences will be enormous hey other
questions anybody would like to raise
please come to the microphone if there
are other people that want to ask
questions you can line up at the mic and
we'll take it I think we have enough
time for maybe three or four depending
on how long the questions and answers
are please thank you very much for your
talk I was wondering what do you think
is a more stable scenario to have no to
ask all the other countries in the end
to get rid of the nuclear weapons or to
have a few number of countries of local
weapons as deterrence a myosin very
simple the nuclear weapons are should be
eliminated and we need to achieve the
world free from nuclear weapons the IAEA
can contribute in many ways in
disarmament we do not replace the United
Nations we are not a negotiating body
but we can contribute through
verification I talked about
non-proliferation because even though
nuclear weapon States eliminate their
weapons suppose them non-nuclear weapon
States develop are there are weapons it
is not am right free from nuclear
weapons nowadays even terrorists can
develop nuclear weapons so our fight
against nuclear security against
terrorists having nutriyum material is
conducive to create a world free from
nuclear weapons and I would like to add
that we are are helping to establish
nuclear weapon-free zones and nuclear
weapon-free zones is another means to
create a word or free from nuclear
weapons okay thank you next question mr.
Amato thanks for coming to see / you
spoke of nuclear energy as a cheaper
alternative
as opposed to fossil fuels do you
believe that holds true after factoring
in public sector subsidies and insurance
policies against disaster the cost and
risk and benefits is undifferentiated of
a cost estimates of nuclear power in
Germany will be different to that in
France there is not a universal cost
risk and some are benefits of of nuclear
power but if a country finds nuclear
power is more advantageous than other
sources which is quite often the case of
the judgment we the IAEA would like to
help them to use it safely securely and
without increasing the risk by the way i
have read out the other day than cost
estimate of our different source of
energy in japan oil nuclear is lower and
an oil oil per kilowatt kenyan ten yen
for one kilowatt geothermal 20 m per
kilowatt solar 40 yen per kilowatt this
is the estimate of japan for the time
being in the future they may change and
I don't know but some cost risk benefit
is a matter that each country needs to
decide and IAEA or United Nations does
not provide that Universal cost but if
they think it is beneficial it is
advantageous they use it and will help
them to use it safely
we'll take one final question okay my
question is actually about one of your
sister agencies UNESCO I sure you know
that yesterday palestine was admitted as
a member state of UNESCO and Palestine
has sort of said that they will be going
around to other agencies and potentially
including IAEA and I was wondering what
your thoughts on that word as far as
some are the IAEA concerned IAEA is an
independent organization established by
its own statute so what happened in
UNESCO does not mean that it will happen
automatically are in the IAEA what will
happen are in the IAEA depends
completely totally on the intention of
member states including Palestine and
some I cannot speak on behalf of
Palestine okay I want to on behalf of
the school and the of international
public affairs and the University
thanked director general Amano for a
very compelling talk and I want to
invite everybody to what I understand is
a fabulous reception out in the in the
lobby here where we can chat informally
again thank you very much sir
you